I don’t know if this is our Marco Rubio
moment…
Certainly I don't think it's necessary to
question the President's motives.
But really I think it's fair to question his
judgment, because he's made the decision that
U.S. policy has to change in order for Cuba
to change.
The reality is anybody that understands or
really cares much about Cuba recognizes the
problem is the regime.
The President has scuttled a policy that's
been based on pre-conditions for normal economic
and political change.
Free labor unions.
Some sort of commitment to holding elections.
Giving people their basic human rights.
Cuba is the only country in the Western hemisphere
that cannot meet any of those conditions.
And I think the President must recognize that
the Cuban people, 11 million Cubans, will
pay the price if the regime feels that it
can act with impunity.
The President can salvage this if he really
insists on fundamental change.
Up to now, he has been pouring on concessions
and getting very little in return.
That has to change.
What do you think about the President’s
trip to Havana?
Please offer your comments and give us ideas
about topics you’d like us to cover in the
future.